let's play arena Darius I think subtly
beats ku thanks talking ooh oh this is
uh what was this is this the same setup
as we had earlier like I had nights but
now I have bishops I remember naka did
not go have this position
try and remember I did watch the naka
video let's just put bishops so unlike
Knights bishops conform batteries triple
battery soon to be quadruple bath
quadruple patterning instantly boom I
think that's already a blunder because I
can take and fork the Queen and rook I'm
probably still worth so egg whites up
why has all these pieces and pawns
yeah Queen 85 I block and attack the
Queen hey Toki Toki Toki Toki
oh hey taki hey Bryan
I think for the tog II bits
yes well take the the rope no this is
kind of what I'm scared of like bishops
don't necessarily like pawn chance like
these two bishops do not like this pawn
chain so I could I could sack I have to
be a little bit careful with this move
maybe there should be five first give
the King some breathing room this still
takes a lot of work to win realizing I
probably could have taken first I mean
now sacking that's interesting
take with this Bishop I mean I guess I
can't complain the position has opened
up and bishops like open positions most
of my bishops defend each other too
which is not a typical thing that you
get to say in normal chests but yeah the
batteries are quite nice I was scared of
this move so do i bonk loud
the problem with bond clouding is Bishop
g4 we have to play King King d1 which is
unfortunate because I'm walking into a
pin and now I'm no longer attacking this
or this but if I get to move my king
over you then it on pins a bishop and
releases some power mmm it's probably a
good move I have a few ideas
there's Bishop d3 kind of like this move
though because block does not want to
play be fine unless block wants to play
d5 but the idea the ideas to keep that I
picked if I'd move back there is Knights
like here would be annoying
hmm it's a bold move I think black I
think black thinks that the bishop the
type but the bishops not attend because
this bishop defense which means I'm free
to do whatever I want
I guess tonight's unpin I was probably
the point okay so I'm threatening this
pawn
I'd be very nice like and I start
getting initiative on the King another
kind of strategy which I'm just
realizing 8b chefs dad else yeah I
should have said that at the beginning I
can still say eight bishops for those
I'm realizing a strategy it's important
to keep a balance between light squared
Bishop sand dark squared Bishop this is
probably a really good move those blacks
threatening this and that's why I was a
very good I'm in trouble
and I could move all the way back and
then try and trap the Queen Wow is that
the Queen trap I'm like the Queen trap
or it might not be a queen trap take my
bishop
oh no my dition yeah so now Bishop b3
I think the Queen's trapped I could also
take your first probably more logical
actually wait now I have to worry about
Bishop g5 yeah let's play a little clip
there should be three first the Queen
trap
yeah the bishops actually work really
well together here I control all these
squares and these squares and the square
and there's no counter-attack against
the King the sad thing is I'm probably
still worse but at least this is
momentum I'm only gonna lose like one
Bishop for the Queen I think more
careless it's too late now and there is
a there's an idea like if Queen takes b3
then I don't take back immediately but I
take care first and then take that I'm
just accounts don't like counting I
might be better here because okay
imagine like imagine takes takes here
and then takes so these two bishops
cancel out rip in peace Queen rip in
peace yeah so these two bishops cancel
out so obviously have I for bishops for
rook knight in four pawns so 4 times 3
is 12 5 plus 4 plus 3 is also 12
I do the math craft so it's equal
material oh yeah we chest tells us it is
equal material 12 on 12 but very
imbalanced always play King be warned
I think of objectively white should be
better though because the bishops can be
used to win pawns they can also be used
to form a a wooden shield but this is
not wooden it's more powerful than wood
steel look at this at this they control
so many squares like more I would
imagine more than half of the squares on
the board are controlled by my bishops
I'm not sure though close to half oh but
I only have two lights for bishops left
be careful about that
there's increments black wants to push
up on that's dangerous I'm realizing I
don't have a clear threat oh I probably
want to train a trading dark-squared
bishop makes a ton of sense because
bishop then I'll just dominate the door
experience I'm having some some
prediction that I'm gonna eventually
have to meet with two bishops we'll see
if that comes true
yeah I don't want to trade
so let's not trade yeah so five bishop
flow still equal material kind of way
there's a define attempting to trap the
rook like these bishops are so powerful
now like the rook is being suffocated in
the center of the board I guess without
g4 weights rook g4 Bishop e6 mate cleric
can't leave the file I'm winning the
exchange how the king's animating net
yeah because I'm already controlling
these squares fool tricky move clicking
c1 and here and then here oh I was this
I have to calculate that's probably good
somehow I'm not sure how didn't really
have much choice after vision d3 so here
here here take stakes and then where's
my mate even if I could just win the
rook I mean I could check and win the
pond never going into it
confusing position very confusing I am
looking for quiet moves I wanna play
this one night before is kind of
annoying tonight as always awesome
stream things love HS we share dance
yeah I actually had this idea I mean it
should give credit to Hikaru he was the
first to do this I'll be about a year
ago my chest calm but then like the idea
came to me that could do without me
chess maybe a few weeks ago and I forgot
about it but then I remembered I'm kind
of running out of digits flicky for this
is a good square in relation to the
night cousin I can't really check me so
soon
it offends both bishops I think the goal
is to trap the rook I'm controlling some
squares ooh wait why maybe opponent is
scared now I have to be
like if I take them it's just a draw
this should definitely be waiting though
three bishops races and nights actually
I'll just play this to keep the as long
as I keep two bishops of different
colors yeah now I'm winning the Knights
creepy ships is funny how my meat for is
a mate to use my king
I'm still not seeing the meat go let's
just take a pause okay so I controlled
the square I'm gonna move my king in and
then ya drive the kings of the corner
check Oh get ready for it get ready for
it now King King b5 so all the bishops
play a role in I mean that's so nice hey
it's chess pay
didn't I just mention chest pain at some
points I think chess players are the
genius so I have a youtube video a few
days ago where people criticized me in
the comments it was like one of these
weird games right i had under promoted
and i ended the game with three bishops
i have a very similar position where i
played this and people criticized me
that i should have moved my team further
so all the dishes play a role in the
mains so hopefully this makes up for it
anyway yeah that probably goes on
youtube as well that was fun it's fun to
play with my 94 hspace saying odd
schemes do very well on youtube yeah